bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors une levée
de brevets qui est suggérée par les ong
oxfam et cela pour éviter un engorgement
de vaccins ce que c'est une bonne idée
selon vous tend à porte
oui c'est une bonne idée ça fait en
réalité des mois quand on demande la
levée de ces brevets et je vous rappelle
que les pays tels que l'afrique du sud
avait demandé dès octobre 2020 une levée
des brevets et aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
ya une inégalité vaccinale qui est
absolument scandaleuse qui en plus se
fait sur le dos de l'argent public avec
des profits qui sont ramassés qui sont
faramineux parce que vous avez rappelé
et à l'heure le prix des doses qu'ils ne
prenaient pas en compte par exemple le
coût de la recherche
mais il ya des millions d'euros des
milliards d'argent public et ont été
investis dans la recherche
aujourd'hui on a une urgence s'élever le
s'élever les brevets parce qu'on a quand
même un virus qui circule plus vite que
le vaccin c'est un problème alors qu'on
a des sites de production qui serait
capable de faire 1 proximité ces vaccins
s'ils avaient une levée des brevets
c'est une véritable question politique
c'est une question sanitaire
c'est une question d'humanité parce
qu'on a un virus mondial et si on ne
vaccine pas aujourd'hui la population
mondiale à grande échelle ne sortira pas
de cette crise là et je termine juste
sur un chiffre vous l'avez dit on a
quasiment dans le 48% de la population
aujourd'hui européenne qui est vaccinée
si on prend l'afrique c'est moins de 2%
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un problème
très sérieux et que les variantes
d'ailleurs se développe dans les pays ou
qui ne sont pas vaccinés et qui après
vont être amenées sur des pays qui sont
vaccinées donc c'est une question qui
est j'ai envie de dire qui est
extrêmement sensible et que tout le
monde peut très bien comprendre si on
vaccine pas tous les pays dans le monde
on ne sortira pas de cette crise là vous
avez souligné donc une situation qui
creuse les inégalités entre les
différents pays dont ils n'ont pas le
même accès aux vaccins
philippe béchade lv des brevets
justement est ce que réellement cette
levée de brevet peut pallier à cette
inégalité et permettre un meilleur accès
à la vaccination dans le monde entier
la levée des brevets ça me paraît
compliqué puisque
la france vient de signer le temps avec
pfizer biotech un contrat comporte 122
close
un bon nombre de ces clauses d'ailleurs
porte sur le secret de fabrication le
respect de ce secret l'impossibilité de
faire fabriquer sans l'accord ou en or d
intermédiaire agréé par pfizer viande
tech et il ya en fait tout un tas de
clauses qui sont assez troublante que
l'on pourrait d'ailleurs qualifié de
littéralement léonine puisque par
exemple quand elle reconnaît que ce sont
bien des vaccins en à mm à c'est-à-dire
autorisation de mise sur le marché
provisoire
les essais donc se prolongeant jusqu'à
fin 2022 ou 2023 et dans ses 122 close
il il est vraiment inscrit en toutes
lettres et avec diverses degré de
précision que si jamais on découvrait
des effets secondaires non anticipés il
sera impossible à l'état français
non seulement de se retourner contre 13
heures mais il ya plus fort c'est que si
jamais il y avait des procédures des
plaintes déposées l'état français
s'engage également à prendre à sa charge
les frais d'avocat 2 riser biotech
donc je dois dire que la la divulgation
des brevets il va falloir revenir sur
certaines de ces clauses ça promet des
discussions animées à mon sens ça
m'apporte pas pour réagir à ce que je
viens de décrire
philippe béchade vous pointer la
responsabilité
l'inaction justement des pouvoirs
politiques
évidemment c'est une question politique
qui convient d'évoquer la question des
négociations et des clauses qui a des
contrats qui seront passés avec big
pharma qui sont aujourd'hui en position
de monopole
mais je le rappelle une nouvelle fois
ses laboratoires là ils sont
subventionnés et il en
reçus décembre astronomique d'argent
public pour développer ces virus à ses
vaccins pendant un temps extrêmement
rapide ce qui est quand même une
prouesse technologique il faut aussi le
reconnaître mais c'est parce qu'ils
avaient de l'argent public a été
distillée là dedans pour permettre de
créer un vaccin est aujourd'hui le
pouvoir politique il a son rôle à jouer
et c'est à dire qu'il doit imposer ses
conditions
gilles doit conditionner l'argent public
qui donne à ces grands groupes là pour
créer des vaccins je suis désolé parce
que manuel macro qui communique un peu
partout en disant qu'il est pour la
levée des brevets qu'il est pour
permettre de partager les savoirs pour
créer des brevets il dit ça quand il
était sur le territoire français mais
ils lèvent pas le petit doigt quand il
est au sein de l'union européenne et des
instances internationales
aujourd'hui on a un pouvoir politique
qui ne prend pas le dessus et qu'il
laisse ses big pharma dicter leurs lois
qui sont en position de monopole
il ya deux sujets il ya effectivement la
vaccination de masse pour lever les
brevets et permettre à des pays de le
produire tels que l'afrique du sud qui a
des capacités pour le produire si on lui
donne aujourd'hui la recette
il ya aussi la question de la
financiarisation de la santé de les
sortir des logiques
ultramar chante parce qu'aujourd'hui on
voit que les profits qui sont faits là
et quand on voit qu'une dose elle coûte
1 euro ou de dollars et qu'elle ait
revendu 20 fois son prix là qu'on voit
que pfizer va faire quasiment je crois
80 milliards de chiffre d'affaires sur
l'année 2021 et qu'il refuse de livrer
ses brevets et de rendre accessible le
vaccin la population mondiale
alors qu'on a des catastrophes
aujourd'hui quand on voit ce qui se
passe au sénégal quand on voit ce qui se
passe en tunisie
ça doit quand même interrogé sur le fait
que la santé c'est un bien commun et on
dort dans une santé universel accessible
à tous et à tous dans cette véritable
manque une solution c'est de le vrai les
brevets pour permettre aux pays les plus
pauvres d'avoir une vaccination est
actionnaire population philippe échec
sur le monopole justement des big
pharmas que souligne thomas porte
c'est vrai que les pays africains
tentent aussi de haut niveau de la
recherche
fabriquer leur propre vaccin en tout cas
ya des initiatives dans ce sens mais il
ya aussi le système kovacs dont
bénéficie dont doivent bénéficier les
pays africains c'est déjà un peu le cas
est ce que pour vous le système kovacs
et la continuité dans une sorte de
monopole justement des big pharma ou pas
dans l'esprit oui mais je sais pas je
vais pas faire une révélation mais j'ai
quand vous parlez de l'éléphant dans le
corridor
figurez vous que si un pays africain
l'afrique du sud a été nommé et je veux
dire avec beaucoup de pertinence parce
que c'est vrai que c'est un des pays qui
a le plus en capacité sur ce continent
de produire des vaccins sur le continent
asiatique
ce serait la ddt sachant que aussi bien
l'inde que l'afrique dépendent de
matières premières qui viennent
majoritairement de chine je referme
cette parenthèse qu il y en imaginant
donc que l'inde ou que l'afrique du sud
parviennent à développer leur propre
vaccin
eh bien figurez vous que dans le contrat
qui lie désormais d'état français avec
le kaiser et bioéthique
il est stipulé que si jamais d'autres
vaccins arriver sur le marché le l'état
français ne peut pas se dédire ne peut
pas suspendre le contrat refuser les
doses de vaccins mais ça va plus loin
puisque 500 biotech donc se protège non
seulement contre des vaccins qui
pourrait être développé dans d'autres
pays et qui pouvaient d'autres qui
pourraient donc être administré en
france mais ça va au delà du vaccin
c'est à dire y compris d'autres
traitements sans préciser exactement
lesquels mais en imaginant qu'on ait
d'autres formes d'administration d'un
traitement anti coded files heures à
lier la france avec l'obligation
d'acheter des centaines de millions de
doses quand bien même il existerait
d'autres vaccins ou d'autres traitements
donc je dire que là on peut toujours
envisager des levées de brevets ou des
collaborations
mais tout ça est déjà tué dans l'oeuf
par le contrat qui lie la france
notamment avec pfizer bibliothèque
thomas porte pour justement limiter leur
éventuel monopole des big pharmas t ce
qui est prévu ce qui a des choses
prévues des sanctions possibles ou pas
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de sanction
puisque ça vient de rappeler les les big
pharmas cas il met en place des contrats
notamment avec les états pendant cette
pandémie met des clauses qui sont
absolument pour nous scandalise
puisqu'elle empêche toute sorte de
négociation il se protège de tout et en
plus s'il ya des frais à prendre en
charge ça a été dit c'est en plus l'état
français qui devrait prendre en france
en charge ces frais là mais je crois que
ça pose aussi la question de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui là qu'est ce qu'on dit
depuis longtemps c'est à dire un pôle
public du médicament en france
quelles recherches sur le médicament en
france on peut pas quand même passé sous
silence une entreprise comme sanofi qui
a reçu quasiment 100 millions d'euros
par an sur les dix dernières années en
termes de crédit impôt recherche qui n'a
pas été un caprice tétreault un vaccin
on a une onde un véritable déficit de
recherche et développement puisque
sanofi tout l'argent qu'il a reçu la
distribuer en dividende a abandonné la
recherche
donc ça me pose cette question là et
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est pour ça
que je dis c'est une véritable question
politique il faut que les politiques
reprennent la mer aujourd'hui sur les
sur le big pharma puisque la question de
santé publique
la question de vaccination c'est pas une
question financière c'est une question
de protection des populations c'est une
question de sauvegarde de la planète et
de l'humanité
donc il ya des décisions politiques
s'imposent elles sont de rupture avec le
modèle capitaliste qu on a commis depuis
des années il faut avoir du courage
politique pour prendre ses décisions
donc c'est ça aujourd'hui il faut sortir
de cette logique marchande où on est
soumis au big pharma je rappelle quand
même et je termine là dessus qu'au début
des négociations on n'avait même pas le
droit de consulter les contrats qui
lient et big pharma avec les états
européens il ya dû avoir une bataille
des députés européens pour qu'on puisse
avoir la publicité de ces contrats donc
c'est cette opacité elle absolument
scandaleuse merci à vous merci à vous
tous m'apporte porte-parole du mouvement
générations point s et philippe béchade
rédacteur en chef de la bourse à au
quotidien